[Music]
so imagine you get your driver's license
right and so the way you decide to
celebrate is the second you're driving
away from the DMV you crack open a beer
hell yeah [__] and you're going a Don
and you're going like 50 Mi above the
speed limit that's Freedom baby that's
tight that's what this guy did now did
he crash no but he got pulled over right
away oh my God
idiot yeah and that's literally the
whole article so let's this I think
that's I think teacher I think that's
Justified police
brutality yeah kind of just just like a
couple of hits if the cop pulls you over
right license and registration and you
don't even have the real card I have the
temporary print out the paper still
hotal is still fresh okay quack quack
quack 25 so he's not a oh boo dud wa he
just got a driver's license at 25 so is
he a l
yeah cuz look he obviously doesn't make
good decisions if you're crack cuz who's
closer to the rule book than that guy he
just finished reading the book he just
finished doing the perit test he knows
that's not he knows it better than us he
knows it better than us yeah that's a
premeditated move that's yeah that's
first a beer ready that's first degree
DUI it might have been a warm beer who
knows if it's cold y I mean if it was
just one beer though is it that bad
that's true according to law yeah 50
like 50 m an hour above the speed limit
above the speed so if oh crap that's a
lot yeah yeah that's a lot like if it's
a 40 mph they're going like 90 yeah open
beer that's fast and free that's the
same thing as like getting your like CCW
license and going outside drinking a
beer going bang bang bang
yeah that sounds kind of cool that's way
cooler that's cooler it sounds like a
Cry for Help maybe huh his parents or
something like something we don't like
to empathize with these people
so I watched this uh this interview it
was like back in the day like it looked
like 1960 or something right where um
drunk driving was not illegal yet I
think this was like in the UK I saw that
same one yeah and then he was just
asking you know people like about the
new law yeah how what they think about
it and there he's asking people after
the bar so they're drunk oh [__] yeah
and it's hilarious you think they're
just better driers men men and women and
they look like completely normal people
men and women they probably weren't
driving that fast were they they'll be
just like oh no I actually drink better
I I drive better when I'm drunk or like
yeah like yeah just helps me relax and
like yeah and it's yeah it's crazy
they're all like opposed to it they're
just yeah they didn't like they didn't
like it that's crazy that I one we are
of our times yeah have have you ever got
a DUI nuh not yet not a real Korean
today
today once I leave here I'm getting one
do a lot of Koreans get du that what you
said I don't know we just left the trink
though oh but you'll get caught no
Koreans won't get di because they got
that [__] underground Uber service
and [__] like that where they secretly
hand each other like cards and
matchboxes where you could just hit up a
random old Korean dude oh I have a
Korean taxi number if you guys that's
what I'm talking about right I remember
the first they do LAX I remember
learning about this before Uber and Li
wow before Uber and Li the phone number
is always on a lighter yeah and then and
then you call them they take you home or
if your car is there you call them let
them know yeah and they bring two people
and they drive your car home it's only K
Tok service they don't do it for other
RAC that's word of MTH we did it too hey
give that give that guy's number to this
guy so when he goes to LAX he doesn't
get the wrong taxi I almost beat up a
Armenian Taxi Driver you just want to
beat everyone up yeah I don't want to he
was asking for it he was asking for it
oh yeah oh yeah but I didn't though see
he progressed a lot with his anger
management
I didn't you know what though Davis so
pushed them but I didn't do anything
he's a Korean male too guy he has to
push him Korean anger do you got that
Korean anger when you get like drunk or
something do you have that anger I
didn't drink till I 21 cuz I was scared
I would be one of those belligerent
drunks oh kage it turns out I'm peace
loving that's awesome hey that's a
blessing you think that's Southern
Hospitality or you think that's how
would you know that you're drunk oh your
mind you're like peaceful
peaceful I get all gay and call my
friends I love you like I FaceTime all
my not not as often anymore but then
that's that's a nice kind of drun yeah
that's a great Dr you got Asian GL no
luy it's in my je I can drink because of
my DNA like my mom drinks a lot she
doesn't drink she she's a she's woman of
God but it's just no it's just like
gentic she's one of those where she
doesn't have to drink for like 10 years
but on a good night when everything's
just kind of in syn out she can drink
and just have a great time when my mom
and my dad first started dating my dad
was trying to be all cool was like every
shot you take I'll take two and she's
like are you sure all right and then he
he's done
dead that's badass damn that's so funny
he's like I gambled and
loosed [__] I told her oh how
much Hennessy can you drink Hennessy
wow shout out to
H have has Uber ever glitched on you
guys what does that mean so like one
time I had a you know like the Uber like
a mat Uber driver right so a guy came
here he was like one of those Chinese
drivers so his English was really really
bad and then I never try to let people
know that I speak Chinese so that I have
that distance so we we matched that
makes sense though it really makes sense
cuz then they'll pull like the whole
Chinese card [__] or whatever so we
what's the Chinese card good question go
beyond the rules now so I like that
professionalism you know like it's like
if you're my real estate agent stay my
real estate agent don't be like hey uh
you want to play soccer with my son I'm
like no I don't want socer
with yeah he he'll like light a
cigarette immediately if you know lines
get crossed hell
Chinese
wife do you want to be
my yeah massage this side and then go
this side
I any of thatass so I gave him the car
and then um the the Uber thing like his
app wouldn't accept the ride and then
like it's it just shows our dots like
this huh like his he wasn't accepting I
wasn't on a ride and then I was like oh
I really have to get to the airport and
he goes ah okay okay okay so he just
starts driving and the whole time we're
putting our phones next to each other
and we're just moving together but the
ride is not accepting oh [__] and then
he's and then like once we got there um
I was like so how much do I pay you he
goes I don't even know it does the
charge whatever and then I was like [__]
and he goes you know what it's okay I'm
like dude this is the nicest Chinese guy
ever I still you gave him 60 bucks I was
like it's probably 60 bucks to LAX but
it was just crazy the whole [__] time
we turned both our phones off on reset
deleted the app we're just doing this
[__] whole thing together while he's
like [__] and I was like what if it's
not what if it's a Chinese trick and he
was just like this works every time cash
only
baby it's a Chinese trick dude that's a
legit trick Chinese scam I love the
Chinese Uber drivers that have a full
news article they're just reading like a
full one or just playing a YouTube video
yeah they're crazy they have like three
phones they got [__] like the beads
on the chair it's like the beads are
money it's crazy in China they got like
the whole big ass iPads and like three
screens and stuff and they don't they
don't look at the road at all oh that's
tight it's [__] banana driving in a
like being a passenger in a car I was in
China in Beijing it was the scariest
thing oh my gosh honking is a way of
communication oh dude there we're this
close with like a person riding a
bicycle but you know I'm way scareder
here than I am over there La is one of
the worst drivers la la over here it's
like everybody there's rules and
everybody's entitled to thinking that
everybody's going to follow the rules so
they'll drive like 80 and like be on
your phone and [__] whereas over there
it's like nobody's driving [__] 80
mph even though you're like H H but like
because because there's no rules over
there everybody has to pay attention
they are alert yeah here it's like you
could just get T-Bone by a car you
didn't even see coming that's way
different cuz both people on their
phones huh everyone's swerving these
days bro like everyone's just like oh
oops dude I've been hearing more honks
here in La like I didn't hear that many
honks growing up I'm like damn everybody
is honking at each other all [__] day
oh bro cuz you know why cuz everyone
just like stuck at the [__] green
light bro let me tell you this I was at
McDonald's I was at McDonald's at like
9:00 and I was like I had to get some I
want cheeseburgers you me cheeseburgers
and uh there's this
BMW and the rest of the line pulls up
and the cars just parked there and I'm
stuck behind them and I'm like hey yo
like pull the [__] up I want my [__]
cheeseburger did you hit the Honker I
hit the honk I Hit the Lights this guy
wasn't moving then the [__]
McDonald's dude like is like looking out
the drive-thru like yo what the [__]
like you can come forward you can come
forward did he die dude and then this
Chinese dude pulls up next to the car
next to the the parking lot and he's
like right next to the guy and he goes
there's no one in the car what do people
there's no one in the car and I was like
what the [__] and then sure enough the
[__] like five more cars pull up
behind me so I'm stuck in between this
dude and like five cars and I'm like and
I was tripping cuz I was like is this
guy going to [__] like is he is he
just crazy like who knows what this guy
is doing right and then I guess this guy
is knocked out bro passed out or he's
sleeping or he just wasn't responding
his windows were tinted bro he didn't
die the [__] McDonald's people came
out and were like um excuse me and he's
just like chilling they didn't know if
he was sleeping or not he zoned man bro
he was probably [__] drunk something
he was on and he just was chilling bro
he was there the rest of the night they
had toose you get your car so everyone
had a back I looked at the dud I was
like I was like this guy's not moving so
then everyone just backed out and then
we went inside to order I got my
cheeseburger but at that point it took
it took so [__] long I was I don't
even want this [__] thing anymore I
think I saw dead person in the parking
lot the other
day shout out to people out there the
first thing he said this
morning what do you mean here yeah at
the parking lot at the gym and then we
were just um going to work out late
whatever so I think he was dead cuz when
I got there I saw a guy and like he was
on the handicap thingy windows down car
on and he was sleeping like that with
his mouth open so I was thinking oh he's
probably taking a little nap you know
how your mind doesn't go he's dead your
mind goes like yeah I think that's
normal to not go he's dead it's it's
probably go like oh he's probably
napping or something real quick cuz he
had I don't know he doesn't want to
drive glass Hat full guy but like I
after the gym you know we were there for
a solid hour at e no no uh 24-Hour
Fitness
it was late too so it was like 10:
p.m. so dead once I left and we were
right back at the same place walk by the
same car I was like oh that [__]
dead and then Hannah's like should we go
check and I'm all like well I was like
do you really want to see a dead dude
and then she's like maybe we should tell
someone and I'm like well I kind of want
to go over there and poke at him but all
right just to check but like I we drove
past and I'm like yeah that
motherfucker's dead thank God there was
a bunch of security dudes and then
Hannah's like sorry and you know she
like UK people are all polite as [__]
like sorry um don't mean to bother you
but I think that there's a man there he
looks
dead he looks dead W and I was like what
made you think he was dead those like
flies coming out of his mouth well one
the car was on windows are off down all
all down right so the car's just been
running for over an hour and then he's
like head you think he's asleep mouth
wide
open he hasn't moved or anything but
it's just weird like why would you was
he a black BMW this is no no it was like
a SUV what what's weird to me is why
turn on the car and then fall asleep he
might be on he might be on one of those
fent but the window's open old man oh
yeah that's another thing too he was
like a he was like a grandpa he was like
a like a so I thought maybe he had a
heart attack or something um if he was
young maybe just you know a loser but
like yeah he was an old man Grandpa
mouth wide open just like in a position
like this and um I think he was dead
yeah